مقره المنظمات الانسانيه في افغانستان
ابوابها موصده اغلقتها طالبان لا بمسلحيها
ولكن بقراراتها مثل منع المراه الافغانيه
من العمل ففي اواخر 2022 قررت القياده في
قندهار منع الافغانيات من العمل في
المنظمات الانسانيه التي كانت توظف النساء
في مد يد العون الى نساء اخرىات يعشنا
وضعيه ماساويه في مجتمع محافظ يحرم
الاختلاط
المنظمات ارادت اقناع الحركه بالتراجع عن
قراراتها
فقامت بتجميد انشطتها تجميد تزامنا للاسف
مع انخفاض قياسي في درجات الحراره الى 34
مئويه تحت الصفر
التضخم وارتفاع اسعار وقود التدفئه
الجنونيه في بلد يعيش على المساعدات ادى
الى تسجيل اكثر من 160 قتيلا نصفهم ماتوا
تجمدا في الاسبوع الماضي
الشتاء القارس وشح المنتجات الغذائيه
عناصر تضافرت مع توقف النشاط الانساني
لتصعد بنسب سوء التغذيه في هذا البلد
الفقير الى مستويات قياسيه حيث ارتفعت
نسبه الافغان المعرضين للمجاعه بسبعه
وخمسين في المئه اي ما يفوقوا 25 مليون
شخص انس من الماسي العربي العربيه